[Music]  i'm on my way to that health retreat i  was telling you about  apparently i'm in need of some fixing  welcome to tranquillium house  we're gonna get you well this is gonna  be the best thing  it has to be are you happy with your  life  we're not in a good place either we try  or  [Music]  we don't it's very intimate here  and how many girls are there nine total  i'm not sure i'm really supposed to be  here some doors are meant to stay closed  has he met her the woman that runs it  she mixes and matches her guests like a  cocktail  supposedly she completely changes people  you came here to heal  this is going to be a wonderful journey  sometimes it'll be unpleasant  i don't want to suffer you're already  suffering  i've been feeling unlike myself there is  nothing to fear  [Music]  you